how promising in the near term in your
view is brain machine interfaces those
starting to allow computers to talk
directly to the brains Elon Musk is
working on that with neural link and
there's other companies working on this
idea
do you see promise there do you see hope
for near-term impact well every
technology has pluses and minuses
already we can record memories I have a
book the future of the mind or eye
details some of these breakthroughs we
can now record simple memories of mice
and send these memories on the Internet
eventually we're going to do this with
primates at Wake Forest University and
also in Los Angeles and then after that
we'll have a memory chip for Alzheimer's
patients well test it out in alzheimerís
patients because of course when
Alzheimer is patients lose their memory
they wander they create all sorts of
havoc wandering around oblivious to
their surroundings and they'll have a
chip they'll push the button and
memories memories will come flooding
into their hippocampus and the chip
telling them where they live and who
they are and so a memory chip is
definitely in the cards and I think this
will eventually affect human
civilization what is the future of the
Internet the future of the Internet is
brain net brain net is when we send
emotions feelings sensations on the
internet and we will telepathically
communicate with other humans this way
this is going to affect everything look
at entertainment remember the silent
movies Charlie Chaplin was very famous
during the era silent movies but when
the talkies came in nobody wanted to see
Charlie Chaplin anymore because he never
talked in the movies and so a whole
generation of actors lost their job and
a new series of actors came in next
we're gonna have the movies replaced by
rain net because in the future people
will say who wants to see a screen with
images that's it
sound an image that's called the movies
our entertainment industry this
multi-billion dollar industry is based
on screens with moving images and sound
but what happens when emotions feelings
sensations memories can be conveyed on
the Internet
it's going to change everything human
relations will change because you'll be
able to empathize and feel the suffering
of other people will be able to
communicate telepathically and this is
this is coming you describe brain that
in future of the mind this is an
interesting concept do you think
so you mentioned entertainment but what
kind of effect would it have on our
personal relationships hopefully it will
deepen it you realize that for most of
human history for over 90% of human
history we only knew maybe 20 a hundred
people that's it folks
that was your tribe that was everybody
you knew in the universe was only maybe
50 or a hundred with the coming of towns
of course it expanded to a few thousand
with the coming of the telephone all of
a sudden you could reach thousands of
people with the telephone and now with
the internet you can reach the entire
population of the planet Earth
and so I think this is a normal
progression and you you think that kind
of sort of connection to the rest of the
world and then adding sensations like
being able to share telepathically
emotions and so on that would just
further deepen our connection to our
fellow humans yes right in fact I
disagree with many scientists on this
question most scientists would say that
technology is neutral a double-edged
sword
one sword one side of the sword can cut
against people the other side of the
sword can cut against ignorance and
disease I disagree I think technology
does have a moral direction look at the
internet the internet spreads knowledge
awareness and that creates empowerment
people act on knowledge when they begin
to realize that they don't have to live
that way they don't have to suffer under
a dictator
that there are other ways of living
under freedom then they begin to take
things take power and that spreads
democracy and democracies do not war
with other democracies I'm a scientist I
believe in data so let's take a sheet of
paper and write down every single war
you had to learn since you were an
elementary school every single war
hundreds of them kings queens emperors
dictators all these wars were between
kings queens emperors and dictators
never between two major democracies and
so I think with the spread of this
technology and which would accelerate
with the coming of brain net it means
that well we will still have wars wars
of course as politics by other means but
they'll be less intense and less
frequent
you